c'est un cri de détresse que l'on ce
jeune artiste tourangeau de 27 ans déjà
en grande précarité financière
il n'a touché que 300 euros 1 6 mois
malgré la crise sanitaire et économique
aujourd'hui il se bat contre pôle emploi
pour bénéficier de ses droits après
plusieurs recours en vain il décide de
faire une grève de la faim
rémy carton et samuel collard ont
rencontré ce matin
pancarte dans une main tentent dans
l'autre axe elle joue ici sa dernière
carte le pas assuré direction l' agence
pôle emploi de tours nord
et c'est devant l'entrée que le jeune
homme entame sa grève de la faim
j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut j'ai deux
sacs de couchage un matelas de quoi lire
et passer la nuit donc je suis prêt à
rester autant qu'il faudra je déterre
nous sommes déterminés à se faire
entendre
depuis novembre dernier il estime être
arrivé à son objectif basculer sous le
régime des intermittents du spectacle en
2020 il enchaîne les contrats et réalise
les 507 heures minimum demandé problème
en juillet dernier il travaille aussi
comme livreur de pizza sous le régime
général
je pas partis en vacances de l'été j'ai
fait que ça c'est parce que j'étais dans
une telle détresse financière après un
premier confinement j'étais pas
indemnisé donc tu
où j'avais été obligé de le faire quoi
et ensuite donc depuis novembre j'ai mes
heures moi ce que je demande c'est qu'on
me donne mes droits aient cotisé pour ça
c'est pas de l'assistanat c'est des
choses que je mérite en fait un seul
versement pour axel depuis novembre 327
euros
en cause la démission de ce poste de
livreurs de pizzas et la suspension de
fait de ses droits à l'indemnisation
chômage
malgré les recours et médiation
impossible pour lui d'être entendu par
l'organisme et faire valoir ses cachets
réalisé en fin de journée pour l'emploi
nous informe du traitement récent du
dossier et du nombre d'heures suffisant
pour changer de régime
une victoire pour axel officiellement
intermittents du spectacle